[Music]
foreign
[Music]
holiday films then and now welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight let's
start with our buddy Will Ferrell will
is taking us behind the scenes of the
elf moments that made his naughty and
nice list I love you I love you I love
you it didn't dawn on me till the first
wardrobe fitting that it'd actually be
in it for the entire length of the movie
well I thought he looked cute from the
top to the knees
I think his calves need a little Fuller
workout to fill those tights
very first day of
filming was in the Lincoln Tunnel people
really didn't really didn't look at me
twice you were in New York nobody really
cared yeah
they called me and said we're sending
you this group called elf and I said no
you're not you're not sending me a
picture called elf
will manage he ate tons of that stuff
with M M's
guy's mad it's nasty at first but then
it's it's an acquired taste buddy
I think there's something I probably
should tell you will would be nine eight
or nine feet
in front of me we had a small child in
between and we'll we'll sitting on a
board and then the small child feet
would see them you'd see them kicking
bye guys
take care I did the voices of all the
animated characters that was that was a
lot of fun bye buddy I'm Mr nawal yeah
at least I'm gonna say that I try what's
the sense of hurting mom I mean it was a
scene that I was slightly hesitant about
because I didn't know if it would come
off as
slightly weird it was so creepy let me
tell you no
um no it was so sweet
pleasantly surprised at how that all
came together could you imagine Jim
Carrey his buddy he's who was originally
eyed for the role and the Snowballs in
this scene it's CGI
will there ever be a time when there
might be a sequel to elf and maybe so
happy you asked disability we're ready
this is the backdoor sequel to them and
they've asked me to play the elf while
we hold out hope for that one we can
currently watch we'll team up with Ryan
Reynolds and Octavia Spencer in Spirited
out now it's Apple TV Plus's modern
musical version of A Christmas Carol I'd
never done a musical before and I I just
thought it was such a
different creative
reimagining of Christmas Carol in a way
that I'd never heard before
[Music]
I think I'm more comfortable as I've
gotten older I'm more comfortable
sucking at stuff you know and I really
don't believe that you can't really be
good at something unless you're willing
to suck at it
early on will was like I don't wanna I
don't think we should do tap and I was
like thank God we'll set it because I
don't want to tell and then suddenly I
was like when we got there there was
Dolly's taxes
I've tried it in the past and I've never
gotten it down
and he nailed it
but you have called will one of your
comedy icons so what was it like getting
to work alongside I will I will keep it
coming but what was it like working
alongside him because there is that
saying you know never meet your Heroes
it was disillusioning
you know you'd be hard pressed to find
somebody who has contributed as much
rather to the Lexicon the comedic
lexicon as well I am obsessed with that
stuff but what I'm so more like truly
touched by is his Humanity as a person
you're just getting like a real human
person yeah underneath all of that
famous and I love that I could be brown
I could be blue I could be violent these
two definitely had fun from the first
teas of them showing off their pipes to
the final product people are one lazy we
only care about ourselves but this is
not the first time Ryan sings in a
holiday movie
by the moon in the stars in the sky yup
there he is wearing a fat suit in 2005's
just friends High School flashback scene
the makeup process took four hours one
time a woman walked up to me on the
street and asked me if Ryan Reynolds was
inside and that sounds like you have no
idea my dear Ryan played a music exec
who visits home for Christmas and tries
to win back his high school Crush Amy
Smart only problem is his A-list client
played by Anna Faris keeps getting in
the way
he actually helped me get this role so
uh he's he's been amazing Anna actually
beat out Paris Hilton for the part one
that was Loosely based on yep Paris oh
Chris brander I Know Who You Are there
we go yeah you slept with my assistant
never called her back Alanis Morissette
played herself she and Ryan were engaged
in real life at the time and would you
believe Bradley Cooper almost played
Chris Klein's character ding dong
Dusty hey why
are you kidding man I love the notebook
what do you think of when you think of
that movie is it Dusty dinkelman Dusty
Dinkleman yeah that comes back on uh at
Christmas because people yell the dudes
[Music]
that was really fun Amy's so great Anna
Faris Ryan everybody in that picture is
just so funny would you guys like to
join us in a Carol to celebrate the
birth of our Lord
foreign
let's talk Tim Allen now not only is he
the voice of Buzz Lightyear but the man
is also Santa Claus he is indeed and
Tim's continuing Saint Nick's story
jumping back into that signature Santa
suit
Santa Claus when you first put the suit
back on and you walked in it was a real
moment what was it like for you inside I
just came out of the makeup and I was a
little hot and a little bothered and I
was itching and I was going totally
forgot what this is like it's the gift
that keeps on giving but this time
around Santa's Little Helper is Tim's
real-life daughter Elizabeth
[Music]
the 13 year old made her acting debut in
the Disney plus series the Santa Clauses
we were with the daddy daughter Duo on
set as they interviewed each other for
E.T what is the best part of having me
on set with you careful with your words
because you earned it you earned a good
part in a movie that has been dear to me
into fans for a long time you know I
don't say this enough but
being said it's meant the world to me I
wasn't born when the Santa Claus
original movie premiered what do you
remember most about me watching it for
the first time I have this scenario in
my head it was not good
you already answered the question
you looked at the screen
literally and we're like doing the
double look at me and then looking up
there didn't quite get this and then
eventually burst into tears I remember
told you I'd been in the Ripple and
spoke in Santa Claus that's how we knew
all these secrets it got very complex
of course E.T was on the set in 1994
when Tim put on that Jolly red suit for
the first of three installments of the
Santa Claus showing to get down there
that turns out that'd be a tailor the
Beloved holiday classic has become the
seventh highest grossing holiday movie
of all time does this look like a little
weight to you the 2002 sequel is ranked
as the number eight highest grossing
holiday film in the U.S you do not want
to see this or the speedo and of course
et's cameras were there just wanted to
welcome E.T to the
or the toy shop
do I want a cookie yes you get to eat
cookies this is this is one of the
primary benefits of being Santa as for
some behind the scenes secrets
this dance sequence was completely
improvised and done in one take
[Music]
and Tim told us why this mistletoe scene
was actually kind of awkward to shoot
we hardly knew each other and I'm still
like a comedian girl I gotta actually
kiss somebody other than my wife I'm
still kind of creeped out I go I don't
really know you and she goes just go
with it and it was a real wonderful
scene
I know you can never imagine kissing
anyone other than Yasmine cater ever
ever
are you two together oh no
Yeah well yeah we were you know we we
are
smooth
Justin Hartley giving us all the fields
in this new Netflix movie that Noel
diary out now but before that ooh you
know he provided a little holiday
entertainment for our favorite bad moms
[Music]
I don't want to make a huge deal about
this but I'm kind of dating one of these
guys yeah wait which one
Santa number two
E.T was on set in Atlanta with Mila
Kunis Kristen Bell Catherine Han and
Susan Sarandon for Justin's Santa strip
tease which left little to the
imagination what I didn't anticipate was
that that she was going to be vying for
this gentleman's attention got it yeah I
mean in a very innocent way in a very
innocent way it was like um hi how are
you good to meet you Catherine and
um legs go up and here we go let's do
this I've now seen a whole new side of
him uh in this film this size well I've
seen that side I've seen a lot yeah yeah
that's not looking down
he was awesome so game
I'm gonna only do Christmas movies from
here on out I think the This Is Us actor
tones it down just a bit for his current
holiday movie The Noel diary out now the
Netflix romance is based on the 2017 New
York Times best-selling novel Justin
falls in love with station 19's Barrett
Doss while trying to reconnect with his
father it's been over 30 years truth is
if I ever saw him I wouldn't know what
the hell to say to him well maybe if
you're up for a drive
we could script a few lines sort of at a
Crossroads and dealing with his past and
how it relates to his future and his
choices that he's made up to this point
how he's chosen to live his life it was
you know checked every box and yeah yeah
it was exciting
see buddy you're not a cotton head in
any muggins you just
special fans of A Christmas Story will
recognize that special elf not only did
Peter Billingsley have a cameo in that
movie he also had one in Four
Christmases with longtime friend and
producing partner Vince Vaughn is there
another airline that you possibly
affiliated with like a sister airline
that we could just transfer to no
but cousin Airline do you have a cousin
Airline how about like an airline that
your airline's felt up before yeah in
fact Vince co-produced Ralphie's return
in A Christmas Story Christmas but can
we go back to where it all began for
Peter 1983's a Christmas story about a
kid with only one Christmas goal
[Music]
kid we were kids right so we so when we
go to higbee's for example they've got a
slide
and we're kids then you're not keeping
us off that slide and it started going
down normally then on your stomach then
backwards and trying to flip off the end
they're like enough
we didn't even eat lunch we just stayed
on the slide all day it was so cool
[Music]
well a lot of people watched this show
this no tell me the truth a 12 year old
Peter took E.T golfing back in 1984 just
after the release of the original film
he actually beat out 8 000 other boys
for the role of Ralphie including Sean
Aston and Will Wheaton a lot of the time
I get
um letters from teenagers there are
teenage girls most time and they just
say oh I think you have cute cheeks or
something you know yep everyone loved
Ralphie and his imagination his iconic
scene was almost totally different soap
poisoning
we've done it so many different ways
we've done it singing it trying singing
it you know doing all of the lines
singing how's your singing
terrible I can't stand it the film saw
moderate success at its release but in
1997 TNT began airing it for 24 hours on
Christmas day before eventually moving
to TBS which led to the highest ratings
in the Network's history making the
movie a holiday tradition I remember the
first status it got to was cult classic
like people would call it a cult classic
and I thought oh that's kind of cool
like it's got a cult following that's
nice then it kind of permeated in the
mainstream and thanks to that prolonged
success Peter's reprising his beloved
role in A Christmas Story Christmas out
now on HBO Max it's definitely an
exercise I think in Restraint you don't
want the movie to be a bunch of
callbacks or just to fall back on the
original it was really important to me
to be its own story set 33 years after
the original Ralphie returns home for
the holidays after the death of his old
man and tries to recreate his childhood
Christmas Magic for his kids my dad made
this all works so easy
yeah that doesn't mean it was easy and
Peter's not the only OG who makes a
return I tripled
this was definitely a reunion of the Kid
cast and it was a lot of fun to think
okay what would
flick and Schwartz be like 30 years
later Scott Farkas comes back Ralphie's
little brother Randy I think that's one
of the things that makes the movie feel
special and feels like you're right back
in the world these are all the same
actors
that sequel is streaming now on HBO Max
and over on Netflix Lindsay Lohan has
made her rom-com return sometimes you
can't rush things when they announced
that you were doing this film I mean
fans went nuts you know people were
calling it The lohanasan did you feel
that love and did you anticipate that
you know people missing you on our
screen so much I definitely felt it and
it was it was so incredible to just see
how excited people were to have seen me
in a movie again and put the pressure on
for sure so I was like this better be
great
Glee's Court Overstreet comes to
Lindsay's rescue after a ski accident
causes her to have amnesia he's a local
Lodge owner who takes her in without
knowing she's a newly engaged Hotel
heiress my name is
my name is so what are we supposed to do
with her I have a place
does it have room service she's so great
and like made it such a fun experience
it was just so much fun like it was
probably the most fun I've had filming
and on anything I hadn't been on set in
such a long time that I was so excited
to be there
like I wasn't bothered nothing could
bother me I was just in the happiest
spirits and then put Christmas on top of
that it was just a great environment in
Falling For Christmas streaming now
Lindsay gives a nod to her iconic Mean
Girls role with a special rendition of
Jingle Bell Rock she originally pitched
doing the same choreography but stuck
with just singing a few lines
how fun was it game to sing that song
again so many years after Mean Girls it
was fun but I was nervous I was I felt
the pressure of doing it in a way that
people who had seen Mean Girls would
like it the same with Mean Girls we had
the dance behind it this was just my
voice so it was nerve-wracking
foreign
okay we leave you now with a holiday
classic that continues to be recreated
year after year The Nutcracker enjoy
good night everybody
[Music]
the ballet premiered 130 years ago in St
Petersburg Russia but it didn't truly
enchant audiences until the 1960s
today the story of Clara's magical
adventure to the land of the Nutcracker
Prince generates around 50 million in
ticket sales annually and you can enjoy
its most recent interpretation starring
Keira Knightley Helen Mirren and Morgan
Freeman this holiday season right at
home on Disney Plus
good luck my Brave girl
[Music]